ma collègue mode montambault qui est
avec on vient de l'élire qui est avec
louis plamondon
le doyen alors 10 en tête pour le bloc
québécois comment comment trouves cette
soirée monsieur plamondon
oui mais vous savez que notamment dans
été les seuls survivants les lecteurs
cette année il était déjà le doyen de la
chance
mandeure s'appelle des menaces et on
tourne cette élection mais finalement
vous avez des retours
le château dernières semaines parce
qu'on savait pas s'il le vote libéral on
s'appelle qui retourna au foyer la
voiture à de retourner aux fruits au
bercail est allé sur leur tournée
entièrement aussi à l'eac à rester une
force
jon peddie accord dans le comté et ceci
dit viser à 21% mais c'est à peu près
alors là on était assuré 12 c'est vrai
qu'avec notre 30e ressources à la
dernière fois qu'on pouvait gagner alors
c'était c'était notre objectif et
j'avais la machine électorale
extraordinaire et ça vienne était certes
un solide si je suis très emballé de
vivre en corse à une dixième élection et
de relever un défi complètement
différent de la direction selon campagne
a permis de multiplier les soupers
spaghetti tournoi de golf salon
funéraire et ce qui est remarquable
c'est de voir sur le terrain comment
vous connaissez les gens par leur prénom
et leur nom mais que pensez vous de
l'idée de travailler avec un
gouvernement libéral majoritaire
c'est une expérience je trouvais le
couac ont été avec un gouvernement
majoritaire conservateur mme
extérieurement très intéressé on a
travaillé avec les blocs avec monsieur
quétier losc est à majorité à 93 et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on avait obtenu
le rapatriement de la main d'oeuvre par
exemple c'est à dire 250 millions par
année puis on sans emplois fédéraux qui
pense au provincial avec un seul guichet
la formation de la main d'oeuvre
donc on est capable de chercher des
victoires si on réussit à mettre le
problème sur la mappe comme on dit puis
s'arranger pour que les forces vives du
québec nous appuient et bien le
gouvernement a intérêt à régler le
dossier rapidement
alors on va travailler dans ce sens là
ce sera bonne politique d'affrontement
sa voie d'une politique on va chercher
petit pas par petit pas des acquis pour
le québec alors un jus je suis confiant
que ça va bien aller mais surtout que
une bonne équipe le match d'adieu de
travailler à 2 20 derniers milles deux
dernières années à travailler
à dix ça va être beaucoup mieux
malheureusement jour j'aimerais bien sûr
qu'on soit 12 par dix
on ne connaît pas les résultats pour le
chef gilles duceppe
avez vous discuté avec lui de
l'éventualité où ne serait pas réélu
voudriez vous être chef intérimaire
non ce sera fait pas partie de mes
objectifs mais en même temps je
souhaiterais cependant que même si
gilles était défait qu'ils demeurent
chef peut demeurer chef venir deux jours
par semaine à ottawa et ont fait un pas
que ce ensemble on prépare les les
positions pour la semaine il faudrait un
porte-parole extraordinaire du globe à
travers tout le québec
alors je pense que ce serait ça c'est ce
que je souhaite le plus parce que c'est
grâce à lui si aujourd'hui le bloc est
encore vivant puis un refus de la force
à l'écran les résultats il est troisième
pour l'instant je vous remercie beaucoup
monsieur plamondon
oui merci